DAVID: Arun Sundararajan
is a professor
at New York University's
Stern School of Business
and an affiliated faculty
member at NYU's Center for Data
Science and NYU's Center for
Urban Science and Progress.
He is here today to discuss the
sharing economy and the future
of digital governance.
Please join me in welcoming
Arun Sundararajan.
[APPLAUSE]
ARUN SUNDARARAJAN:
Thank you, David.
And thank you,
guys, for having me.
Thank you for taking
time out of your lunch
break to learn more about
the sharing economy.
That's a picture of me
at Google the last time
I visited four years ago.
I was trying out your bicycles.
So this is the book
that you've been given.
I have been a professor at
NYU for more than 15 years
I was never inclined to write
a book until I wrote this one.
It wasn't part of the plan.
The reason why I was motivated
enough to write this book
was that I started getting
interested in the sharing
economy through some examples.
They seemed similar but
in different industries.
You had Airbnb.
You had Uber and Lyft.
You had food-sharing sites.
You had crowdfunding sites.
And over time I started to see
a pattern that they shared.
And I started to see them grow
at the pace that they did.
And I began to
conjecture that we
were seeing the emergence
of a new way of organizing
economic activity.
And so I wrote the
book to try and unpack
what that new way of
organizing economic activity
is, what its economic
impacts are going to be,
how it's going to change
what it means to have a job,
and what it means for the future
of how we regulate business
in the consumer interest and
in the employee interest.
The subtitle of
the book has what
I think is the
most accurate label
for this new way of
organizing economic activity.
I call it crowd-based
capitalism.
That's not the title of the book
because "The Sharing Economy"
maximizes the number of
people who kind of know
what I'm talking about.
And that was my publisher's
decision rather than mine
But let me explain to you
what crowd-based capitalism is
by giving you some examples,
many of which will be familiar.
So when I was a kid, I
would watch television.
I'd watch television
with my friends.
The television programs that
I watched, the content itself,
tended to be created by a
large corporation, typically
a television studio or
a television network.
And then that content
was delivered to me
through the infrastructure
of another large corporation,
either a government-owned
television
station or a privately-owned
television station.
I have a 12-year-old
daughter now.
She watches a little television,
but she watches YouTube.
She watches YouTube the way
that I would watch television.
She watches YouTube
with her friends the way
I watched TV with my friends.
And if you think
about YouTube, it's
a platform owned
by a large company.
But the content that is
being delivered on YouTube
is pretty diverse.
Some of it is created by
an individual amateurs.
Some of it is created
by a group of people.
by small businesses.
Some of it is created
by large studios.
And so we've replaced
the model, or we're
starting to replace the model,
of corporate-produced content--
video content-- with a model
of corporate-delivered video
content but where the content
is created by a distributed
crowd of people of
varying scale and varying
levels of professionalism.
And so this, to me,
is sort of a microcosm
of what's happening in a
lot of other industries.
Philanthropy now has a
crowd-based alternative.
If you want to be
a philanthropist,
you can on Kickstarter.
Again, you've got a platform
that is aggregating requests
for philanthropy, but the
philanthropists themselves
vary in their scale and it's
typically a distributed group
of people who are
collectively crowd-funding
the cause that they believe in.
Traditional venture
capital is being challenged
by a crowd-based venture
capital where a platform
aggregates promising
companies, but the funding
is actually provided by a
distributed group of people.
Some of them are
professional investors.
amateur investors.
If you want to loan, a small
business who wants a loan
can go to a bank.
But they can also
go to a growing
variety of crowd-based
lending platforms.
Let's take Funding
Circle as an example.
It's based in the
United Kingdom.
The typical loan ask on Funding
Circle is 50,000 pounds.
The difference between
the 50,000 pounds
that you get from Funding
Circle and 50,000 pounds
you get from a
bank is that you're
providing the same
kind of documentation
on Funding Circle
as a small business,
but the typical loan is
funded by over 200 lenders,
some lending as
little as 20 pounds.
So we're replacing the model
of institution-based small
business lending with
a crowd-based model
of small business lending.
Many of you have used to
Getaround, a peer-to-peer car
rental company.
There's a competitor,
Turo, which is also
a peer-to-peer car rental.
The platform aggregates demand,
but the supply of the cars
come from individuals who want
to monetize their cars when
they're not driving them.
So, again, we're replacing
the Hertz and Europcar
model with a crowd-based model,
but a platform aggregates
micro-entrepreneurs
of sorts who are
running their own tiny
car rental businesses
through the platform.
We're used to getting our
groceries from a grocery store,
like big food.
There is a small,
but growing number
of peer-to-peer alternatives.
I think the one that I'm
most familiar with is
called La Ruche Qui Dit Oui.
It's based in France.
It has 700 different
locations now.
And it's a platform that
connects the growers of food,
the producers of meat,
the fisher, the people who
are actually catching the
fish with the people who
want to buy their produce.
And so the orders are
taken electronically,
and then sellers and the
buyers are connected.
So it's converting someone who
might have otherwise supplied
a large grocery chain
with the ability
to actually sell to
customers directly and run
their own small micro food
distribution business.
Hotels would either
franchise their brand
to large companies, which
would then build buildings
and dedicate them for
short-term accommodation.
That's being replaced
by a wide array
of crowd-based alternatives
where the demand is still
aggregated by a platform.
Airbnb is clearly the
most visible example here.
But if you think
about who is providing
the actual short-term
accommodation on Airbnb,
it's a couple million hosts
offering 3 million listings,
each of whom, for all
practical purposes,
is running their
own tiny business.
They are managing their brand
through their reputation.
They're setting prices.
They're managing inventory.
They are providing
customer service.
whatever labor inputs
are needed to provide the
short-term accommodation.
The world's largest
hotel chain, which
is the merger of
Starwood and Marriott,
has 1.1 million rooms.
Airbnb has 3 million listings.
By early next year, they
will have over a million
instant book listings.
And so by any
measure, by next year,
they will be the
world's largest provider
of short-term accommodation.
And I say that not to point
out how successful Airbnb
has become, but to
underscore the fact that this
isn't fringe activity anymore.
A lot of these are familiar
things-- giving someone a ride,
accommodating someone,
lending someone money,
supporting a cause
that you believe in,
maybe preparing
food for someone.
But they're starting to
come out of the fringes,
and we're starting to see
platform-based mainstream,
world-class, world-leading
center of the economy
alternatives to the
traditional corporate model
of aggregate resources and
provide goods and services.
How many of you have
stayed in an Airbnb?
hosted on Airbnb?
How many of you
have taken a Lyft?
How many of you have
you taken an Uber?
How many of you have tried
the carpooling feature
that Waze has?
Not bad.
It's still early days.
What I'm expecting to see
tip to crowd-based capitalism
in the future is energy
production and distribution.
Today, energy is
largely produced
by large companies
that accumulate
resources and produce and
distribute this energy.
Once the battery technology
for storing solar power
is good enough to be able
to reliably store it,
you will see local networks
that are platform-based that
will emerge where people
who have excess power
can then redistribute it
to someone who needs it,
either through a
transmission line
or by actually transporting
the battery from one
place to another.
There's a company in China
called Trina Solar that
is thinking about a pilot along
those lines, where the power is
transmitted by actually
physically moving the battery.
So the sharing economy is
much more than the companies
that you hear about in the news,
like Lyft and Airbnb and Uber.
It spans a wide
range of industries.
If you look at all
these industries
and put them together,
they constitute
over half the GDP of a
number of advanced economies.
It's like the digital
transformations
that we saw in advertising, that
we saw in music, that we saw
in video entertainment,
that we saw in publishing
are starting to come
to the physical world.
We're starting to see
digitally-enabled ways
of organizing
economic activity that
are entering the
very physical world
industries of accommodation,
of health care,
of retailing, of hotels,
of transportation.
So I call this new way of
organizing economic activity
crowd-based capitalism.
I see it as the third
phase in-- you know,
I'm a business school
professor, so everything
has to follow three phases.
The first phase was
pre-18th century
when most economies
that were market-based
or that were capitalist
were organized
through markets--
individuals producing
for other individuals.
How many of you have
taken an economics course?
So in your textbook,
you would've
learned about the economy that
was the entrepreneur selling
to the customer.
There isn't so much of a
mention of large companies.
It's more like the
producer and the consumer.
And that was what
the economy looked
like when Adam Smith wrote
"The Wealth of Nations"
in the 18th century.
That was the American economy.
That was the British economy.
But over the 19th
and 20th century,
the world's economy in
many countries reorganized
in a way where hierarchies
of increasing complexity
were created and started
to dominate how people made
a living and how the world's
goods and services were
produced.
So by the end of
the 20th century,
five out of six people who made
a living in the United States
did so by working as a full-time
employee for a company.
That became the dominant model
of how you earned a living.
It became the dominant model
of how the world's goods
and services were produced.
What we're transitioning to
is a third alternative that's
going to set aside managerial
capitalism as a mainstream
alternative to organizing the
world's economic activities
where instead of an institution
accumulating the resources
and hiring the people
and producing the goods
and services itself, that
institution will instead
aggregate production by a
distributed crowd of people,
whether it's lending money
or finding-- offering
accommodation, offering
transportation, food services,
energy, health
care-- all of these
are going to transition
in many sectors
away from the managerial
capitalism model
and towards the crowd-based
capitalism model.
So what I'm going to do
in the rest of the talk
is just give you
a flavor for some
of the features of
crowd-based capitalism
I find interesting, but focus
mostly on digital governance
and regulation, and how I
think the way that we regulate
the world's economic activity
is going to have to change,
and what's actually
happening on that front.
So there are many aspects
of crowd-based capitalism
that I found appealing.
I think it redefines our
notion of perfection.
We are used to expecting
perfectly folded towels that
are all the same color neatly
arranged in our hotel rooms.
Once we start
staying in Airbnbs,
we realize that that
feature of a hotel
may not be as important
as we expected it to be.
We feel impatient when our
room service orders are late
and then you start to wonder,
does this really matter?
So there are aspects
of perfection
that have been over-invested
in by the industrial economy
that we're going to start to
realize don't matter so much.
But I think that a
more compelling change
is the blurring of
lines in the supply
system between the personal
and the professional.
What do I mean by this?
Well, all of you
probably own cars.
How many of you own a car?
I don't own a car.
So I haven't owned a
car for a long time.
So if you own a
car, you've probably
picked someone up from
somewhere, from the airport,
from the train station.
You've probably given
someone a ride at some point.
You've had people stay
over in your apartment
or in your house at some point.
Maybe you've lent
a friend money.
It's quite likely
that if you cook,
you've prepared a
meal for someone.
All of these are
personal activities.
They fell under the
personal umbrella.
You didn't have to go and
apply for a government permit
before you gave
your friend a ride.
It was just assumed that it's
between you and the friend.
And on the other side, you
had professional providers
of the same services-- taxi
drivers, restaurants, bed
and breakfasts, money lenders.
Now what the sharing
economy is doing
is it's blurring the
lines between personal and
professional in the provision
of these commercial services.
It's allowing people
who don't do something
or who aren't trained
to do something
as their full-time profession
to participate as part
of the supply infrastructure,
whether it's lending money,
investing in companies,
providing accommodation,
providing transportation.
And the example
for transportation
that reflects this change that--
the two examples that I find
most compelling because they
are crowd-based capitalism
in the purest form, where
you're taking a distributed
group of people, tapping into
the resources that they have,
and collectively
using those resources
to create something
that resembles
a billion dollar
infrastructure-- the newly
announced Waze carpool
where people can carpool
with other people
through the Waze app,
and the network that has
been created by BlaBlaCar.
How many of you have
heard of BlaBlaCar?
So for those of you who haven't,
it's based out of Paris.
It's got a funny name, a
carefully chosen funny name
that was chosen because it
had extremely high recall.
If I asked you to name five
companies that I talked
about a week from
now, I'm sure you're
going to remember BlaBlaCar.
What BlaBlaCar does is
that it makes it possible
for you to sell
seats in your car
if you're driving from
one city to another.
So if you're driving
from Paris to Leon,
and you're driving by yourself,
and you have three seats,
you can advertise them.
You can say it's
10 euros a seat.
There are leather
seats in my Mercedes.
I play soft jazz.
And I'm a quiet person.
Or you can say I'm
driving my Volkswagon.
I play heavy metal.
And I talk a lot.
You can even rate yourself as
either being blah, blah blah,
or blah blah blah, depending
on how talkative you are.
But here's 12 hours in
the life of BlaBlaCar.
They operate across
22 countries.
The blue dots are
people traveling
in an empty seat in
someone else's car
from one city to another.
You count the
number of people who
travel on BlaBlaCar in France
every day, it's five times
the number of people who travel
on the Eurostar train network.
You add up all the people
who travel on BlaBlaCar
across their countires,
it's way more than
the number of people who
travel on Amtrak every day.
So they've created the
capacity of billion dollar
infrastructure without
spending any money
on new physical investments.
This is pure
crowd-based capitalism.
So this promises a new model for
building infrastructure, which
is crowd-based, where you'd
stop thinking of infrastructure
as being an investment with
high capital expenditure
and start thinking of
it as, well, there's
some underlying
infrastructure-- the roads--
but how do we layer
on top of that
enough so that people will
start sharing commercially
the resources they have to
create new collective capacity?
You can think of this
applying to parking spots.
It's already applying to demand
spikes during a sporting event,
like Airbnb picking up a whole
bunch of the excess demand
during the Olympics or
during the World Cup in Rio.
And I've always understood
why people ride on BlaBlaCar.
I mean, that was like I
understood that instantly.
It's cheap.
It's cheaper than
a train ticket.
The schedule is
far more flexible.
There are people leaving
at all hours of the day.
If your driver is nice, he or
she will come and pick you up.
And so it could be more
convenient as well.
But I never fully
understood the logic
of why someone would
drive for BlaBlaCar.
I mean, you've got
a nice $30,000 car.
Do you really want strangers you
don't know sitting in your car?
And what do you make
at the end of the day?
If you've got three
passengers, 30 euros?
It's decent, but it's
not life-changing wealth.
So I kept asking
the founders, why
is it that people
drive for BlaBlaCar?
And they'd keep sending
me these charts that
say, look, we've launched in
Poland-- hockey stick growth.
And I'd ask again.
And they'd say, well,
consider the following survey
that we've done.
Look at our trust framework.
Finally, after asking
over and over again,
they sent me a picture.
And they said, look
at the picture.
These are two young French
guys, like the picture explains
why people drive for BlaBlaCar.
And this is the picture
that they sent me.
I looked at the picture.
And I said, aha.
I get it.
But it made me think.
And what it made me
think about was--
and this is central
to understanding
one of the fundamental
shifts that
is being caused by the sharing
economy, which is that we have
been accustomed to a narrative
over the last 15 years
about how technology
is isolating.
It takes us further
apart from each other.
It creates digital
tethers where they
used to be high bandwidth,
emotive exchanges that
were face to face.
And this is not a new narrative.
It's something that
Nisbet was talking
about in the '50s when he
talked about the fragmentation
of community.
And Nisbet quotes Durkheim
from his 1897 book
when he talks about how
technological progress--
fundamentally, the narrative is
that it takes us further apart.
Now when I talk to people
who are participating
in this new world of
crowd-based capitalism,
typically they're
drawn to the service
because it's cheaper,
because it's more convenient,
because it's higher quality.
It's more flexible.
But what keeps them
coming back, what
keeps them using the service
is that feeling that they
are forming a genuine connection
with someone else as part
of an everyday
economic activity.
It's not so much about I want
to meet friends and so let me
go on this friend-making app.
It's more about I need a
ride or I need to get to work
or I need a place to
stay or I need a meal,
and we've taken out
all of the community.
We've stripped out of
all of the connectedness
from our everyday
economic activities
over the 20th century as
industrial capitalism reached
its pinnacle.
And I feel like crowd-based
capitalism is re-integrating
into our everyday economic
activities some of what
we yearn for, the simple
connection with someone else,
whether it's sitting next
to them when you get a ride
or that feeling of intimacy you
have when you stay in someone's
Airbnb property even if they're
not there because you're seeing
little slivers of their life,
or like the nicer experience
of sitting at
someone's dining table
and sharing a meal
with a bunch of people
rather than sitting
in a restaurant.
Now the other point that I
want to make with the BlaBlaCar
example is that we are
completely rebuilding our trust
infrastructure.
What do I mean by that?
Well, I've been
surveying BlaBlaCar uses
for a little while.
And this is one of the results
that we got out of a survey
that we ran last year.
It's across 11 countries.
And the question had to do
with, give us the level of trust
that you place in
the following people.
This was surprising not
just because the result
was so striking to us, but
because it persisted across.
It's the same in Russia as
it is in France and Germany.
It's the same in Poland
as it is in Belgium.
And what seems to be the
reported level of trust
that these BlaBlaCar
users have is
that they trust
someone who they don't
know who has a full profile
on the platform at levels that
are comparable to the trust
that they place in friends
and family, higher
than the level of trust
that they place in a
colleague or neighbor,
and much, much higher
than the level of trust
that you place in a random
social media contact.
So this either means
that BlaBlaCar users have
highly undesirable
neighbors and colleagues,
or it means that we've reached
this point where there's
a segment of the population who,
while they stopped trusting--
their level of trust in
institutions has fallen,
their general level of trust in
people in society has fallen,
but they are sufficiently
native in the digital world
that they can look
at a digital profile
and it can cause them to trust
someone who they don't know
sufficiently to
get into their car
and say, drive me
to another city.
I've got ongoing research--
one of my Google faculty awards
is supporting this-- that are
trying to unpack this further,
go beyond surveys, look at
platform data, run experiments.
But what makes me excited about
this is that every time we've
created a new system
of trust in an economy,
the world economy has
grown dramatically.
We moved from
trading with people
we knew in our
village communities
to trading with people we
didn't know once government food
certification came along
and you could buy milk
not just from the person
you knew-- because you knew
it was milk and not just
powder mixed with water--
you could buy the
milk from the person
in the neighboring village
because now the government
had set rules that outlawed
adulteration of food.
As many countries created courts
and contracts and property
rights, that expanded trading
possibilities significantly.
If you think about
the everyday--
just spend 30 seconds
thinking about the things
that you've bought in
the last couple of days--
a cup of coffee or whatever
it is that you bought.
Chances are that you're relying
on brand as a form of trust.
Today that's the
mainstream form of trust
because you don't want to start
sign a contract every time you
go to a coffee shop.
I mean, it's too expensive.
And so, instead,
you rely on the fact
that the business's desire
for your continued business
is going to cause them to invest
the right amount in quality.
And each of these has expanded
commercial possibilities
dramatically.
And so we're on the cusp of
creating a new infrastructure.
It's a combination of existing
things like government IDs,
but new things like bringing
the social network online
through Facebook and LinkedIn,
like increasingly rich peer
feedback systems that
allow you to learn
from the experiences of others.
And that's core to what
is making the sharing
economy possible today.
Because 20 years ago,
we were trading stuff
with people on eBay.
The feedback system was enough
to build trust in someone
you didn't know for them to
be able to send you a package.
What's the worst
that could happen?
Maybe the product was broken?
It wasn't as advertised.
That baseball wasn't real.
It was fake.
The jeans didn't fit you.
The Beanie Baby
wasn't as advertised.
Or you didn't get paid.
Maybe you got paid late.
But the risks were low.
This was low stakes
sort interaction.
And the feedback system
was enough to facilitate
that kind of trust.
But we've expanded
this infrastructure
to the point where we are
engaging in this high stakes
interaction with people now.
If you think about it
having a stranger sleep
in your spare bedroom, which
is what millions of people
do on Airbnb, is a
pretty high stakes kind
of interaction in terms of
the level of trust needed.
And yet it's been created.
So is getting into
a stranger's car
and driving five hours if
you've never met them before.
So given that we've created this
infrastructure of trust, that's
one of the reasons why I
think that we are-- it's
absolutely imperative that
we start to think differently
about how we govern
things and, in particular,
how we regulate business.
There are plenty of examples
of the sharing economy
platforms butting heads
with city and state
governments around the world.
Many of you have heard
about Uber and Lyft
leaving Austin
because they couldn't
come to an agreement about how
drivers should be screened.
They're in the news
every day, like there's
a different city that is
either clamping down or being
accommodating.
Airbnb has been in a multi-year
battle with New York state
regulators about the
legality of their B&B. Even
a small start-up-- and we
were talking about this
before the talk began--
food start-up Josephine that
allows people to prepare meals
and sell them to other people.
They were shut down
in the East Bay
recently over food
regulation concerns.
So part of the problem
here is that we've
got a regulatory system
that is expecting
full-time professionals
and large companies
as the suppliers.
And now we've blurred
the lines between
personal and professional.
And so we've got people at a
scale and a level of activity
where the old regulatory
boxes just don't fit.
And so if someone drives a
Lyft for two hours a day,
do we really need the
same kind of oversight
that we needed for someone
who drives for 12 hours a day?
Someone is preparing
a meal twice a week.
Do we really need the
same kind of oversight
that we needed for someone
who's running a restaurant?
And you might say, yes.
I mean, of course, we do need
the same kind of oversight.
Safety is safety.
But we always make trade-offs.
I mean, you don't
have a food inspector
stationed in every restaurant
testing every piece of food.
We've already said, well,
that's prohibitively
expensive for the
government to do.
So let's make a trade-off.
Let's have spot checks instead.
And so we're willing to
accept some imperfection
in our regulatory
system by weighing
the costs and the benefits.
And now, as the
supply system changes,
so do the costs
and the benefits.
And we have to
rethink regulation.
The fact that the
platforms are providing
pretty robust
digital trust means
that you can start to reduce
the role of the government
in providing those kinds of
interventions that were needed
to prevent market failure.
So if you take the
example of taxis,
25 years ago, I wouldn't have
gotten into a taxi in New York
City unless it had a government
body that was saying,
well, this is a legal taxi.
This is metered fare.
This driver has been
screened and is trustworthy.
This car has been inspected.
In the 1990s, the
taxi market would
have failed completely
unless there
was government intervention.
It was absolutely necessary to
keep the market functioning.
But now you've got
a new third party
that is providing a
lot of trust already.
We've got GPS technology
that maps our route.
Someone else can set a
fare and stick to it.
There's a third party that's
interested in making sure
that the drivers are high
quality, that the vehicles are
inspected.
So I'm not saying we toss the
government regulation out.
But because of this
new way of trusting
that has been developed
between peer-to-peers,
we have to rethink
the role of government
and rethink other ways in
which we start to regulate.
Because it's one thing
to say, well, I've
got this
infrastructure, and it's
going to regulate the 5,000 taxi
drivers in the San Francisco
Bay area.
It's a completely
different thing
if you have half a
million people who
are part of the supply system.
Some of them are giving
Waze carpool rides.
Some of them are driving
Lyfts two hours a day.
Ubers 12 hours a day.
Once you have that
kind of scale,
the idea that the government
is the sole regulator
starts to make less sense.
So what's the alternative?
Well, we've already started to
shift a lot of the roles that
were historically the
government's to platforms
of different kinds.
And you guys work at
Google, so you're already
familiar with this.
But let's put Google aside and
look at some other examples.
It used to be the case that
we would trust the government.
We would entrust the government
with the responsibility
of dividing the rights between
the creators of content
and the consumers of content.
We had copyright that would
say this is what you can
do with a book when you buy it.
And these are the
rights that you
retain if you publish the book.
This is what you can do
with a song that you buy.
And these are the rights
that you retain if you're
the creator of the song.
That division was done through
intellectual property law
and copyright law
by the government.
We have de facto shifted a
lot of that responsibility
to platforms that provide us
with streaming music, platforms
through which we download music,
platforms through which we
buy electronic books.
It's a license now between
you and the producer
of that content that is
mediated by the platform.
There's a host of
other examples where
this sort of responsibility
that was the government's
has tacitly shifted
to the platform.
And so we have to
embrace the idea
that many of the
functions that used
to be performed
by the government
can now be performed
by a third party.
So what are my
answers to, well, how
do we deal with
regulation in a world
where it's quasi-professionals,
the scale of supply
is orders of magnitude higher
than just a few hundred
large corporations who can be
regulated by the government?
Well, I have three key ideas.
One is to increase the
level of pure regulation
where people who are
participating in the system
start to become part of the
regulatory solution as well.
So take the food
preparation example.
Rather than having the
restaurant inspector inspect
every kitchen that is going
to be used to produce a meal,
whether it's 10 meals a day
or one meal every three weeks,
instead have experts
on the platform start
to regulate the novices.
Start to have some internal
peer-to-peer regulatory system
as an alternative to it all
flowing from the government.
So that's one thing that I
think will start to expand.
The second sort of
government solution
that I anticipate
an expansion of
is self-regulatory
organizations.
This doesn't mean no regulation.
It doesn't mean deregulation.
It just means some of
the regulatory activity
is conducted by an institution
other than the government.
So we've had self-regulation
through history,
from the merchant
guilds in medieval times
through the
20th-century economy.
Nuclear power has
successful self-regulation.
The cotton industry has
Financial services as a
lot of self-regulation,
and the people argue whether
that's successful or not.
The chemical industry, there's
a lot of self-regulation.
And so this is not a new idea.
And the stakes in many
of the industries which
we accept self-regulation
are comparable at least
to what's at stake with the
short-term accommodation,
point-to-point transportation.
I think there's also
sort of some evidence
that the American
Medical Association is
a self-regulatory organization.
The bar associations are
self-regulatory organizations.
The national
Realtors Association
is a self-regulatory
organization.
And they play a part in
regulating health care
provision, provision
of legal services,
and the selling of real estate.
Part of the reason why
you have self-regulation
as part of the solution
in these industries
is that they tend to
be more peer-to-peer
than, say, the production
of-- I don't know-- cars.
And so individual
providers tend to be
more prevalent in medicine,
in law, in real estate.
And so it seems
like the presence
of a self-regulatory
organization
is a natural complement
to a supply model
that is more peer-to-peer.
And the final prescription that
I've been giving governments
around the country and,
actually, around the world
in terms of
regulatory approach--
and this is the
last point I make
before I stop for questions--
is data-driven delegation.
To me, this is my competing
proposal to open data.
Open data is very
popular these days.
Every city government I talk
talks about their open data
initiative.
And this has two sides to it.
One side has to do with making
available data that governments
collect about us.
But another side
to it tends to be,
well, if you're
operating in our city,
then you need to
give us some data.
So Uber and Lyft hand over
data to many city governments
like New York City that provide
details about every ride
that they give.
And this is supposed to be
part of a regulatory solution.
I'm not a big fan of
that part of open data.
I think it's much
more efficient instead
to delegate the regulatory
responsibility to the party
that holds the data.
And so, let's say
that you want Airbnb
hosts to pay hotel taxes.
Whether or not
that's a good idea,
let's put that
aside for a second.
But let's say that
the government
has decided that Airbnb
hosts are like hoteliers
and need to pay-- whatever-- 14%
of their revenue as hotel tax.
They can either say,
register with us
and we'll collect
the tax from you.
Or they can tell Airbnb,
listen, you already
have all of the data.
Why don't you just
collect the tax for us
and give us an audited response,
and remit the tax to us?
We don't need a system
for registering.
And a lot of cities are
trying this-- delegate
the responsibility
to the party that
has the data for
actually enforcing
whatever rules are necessary.
Or take the example of-- there's
a widespread casual evidence
in New York City
that the yellow cabs
in New York City discriminate
against passengers
of certain ethnicities.
There are laws
against this, but they
have been impossible to
enforce from the looks of it.
I mean, what are
you going to do?
You can't have people
standing on the street corner
flagging down taxis that
don't pick up people.
Now we live in a world now
where an increasing fraction
of those rides are
provided by Uber and Lyft.
There's a data trail
about pick-ups.
Or consider the situation
that certain guests on Airbnb
are facing, where they feel like
people of certain ethnicities
don't get accommodation
as easily as others.
The data driven delegation
approach here would not
demonize the platform,
but instead say,
well, you are a partner.
You are part of the solution.
You're not creating
the problem here.
You're just manifesting
certain deficiencies
that human society has in the
interactions that are being
captured on your platform.
Why can't you use
your data trails now
to detect and correct
the kind of behavior
that we consider undesirable?
It's been hard to capture this
kind of behavior in the past.
And so data-driven delegation
is a way of saying, well,
if there is a data trail
through which behavior
that might need to be
corrected through regulation
can be detected, delegate the
responsibility of enforcing
those kinds of rules,
or even with coming up
with rules on your own, to the
platform of the entity that
holds the data.
Don't say, well, platform
give me your data.
That seems far less efficient.
And YouTube practices
data-driven delegation
on a daily basis with
their algorithms.
And there are different
ways in which decisions
are made about whether
video content should
be streamed or not.
I mean, it's inconceivable that
you have a government authority
regulating content on YouTube
at the same level of granularity
and with the same
level of accuracy
that YouTube can do on its own.
Now you might ask,
well, what happens
when the interests
of the platform
diverge from the
interests of society?
What happens when,
say, the platform has
a certain set of objectives
that they want to fulfill,
but society's objectives
are different?
Maybe there are
externalities, maybe
we feel the platform is
over-providing certain
regulation, under-providing
other regulation.
So you have to give them rules.
And you have to figure
out a way in which they
comply with these rules.
Well, the 20th-century
solution would
be to say, well, give
us an audited report.
But I've started to think
of an audit as just one
particular response
to a specific query.
We query publicly-traded
companies every quarter
and say give us the
following summarized data.
It's of a specific kind.
And every company,
instead of turning over
every single detail
of their operations,
every publicly-traded company
puts out a 10-Q. Every year,
they put out a 10-K.
But that's the response to
one particular kind of query.
And so I'm starting to see
more potential in the idea
that as you delegate regulatory
responsibility to platforms,
you also create some sort of
limited API infrastructure
where compliance with these
delegated responsibilities
can be verified
by a third party.
So I'm still early
in my thinking there,
but I wanted to toss
that idea out there
because I'm sure
that some of you
might have some
thoughts about it.
But let me stop there.
But this is where you can
reach me in case in the next 15
minutes of questions, you
don't get to ask your question,
or you decide not to.
I'm easy to find on a
wide variety of platforms.
So thank you for coming.
And I look to your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I really liked
what you said about trust.
And one of the points
that I believe you made
was that one of the reasons
why that trust in the sharing
economy is so high
is because people
are able to learn from other
people's past experiences
and read reviews and
these sorts of things.
But one question that I have is
that institutions and resources
determined by public
opinion really
isn't that new of a thing.
If you think about even
voting in government,
most officials are
elected by the public.
And people are well aware
that those decisions are
made based on public opinion.
And yet, trust in
politicians is extremely low.
So, really, the kind of trust
that exists within the sharing
economy is somewhat new and
revolutionary, and possibly
even quite an exception.
I was wondering what you feel
has happened within the sharing
economy that has made that
trust succeed in a way
that it hasn't in the past.
ARUN SUNDARARAJAN:
That's a great question.
I think the ways in
which we could come up
with crowd-based
decisions in the past
have been at a very coarse
level of granularity.
It hasn't been possible
to delegate responsibility
for collectively making a
decision on small decisions
to a group of
interested stakeholders
because the process of running
an election is expensive.
And so the big decisions, like
who should run the government
or who should be my
elected representative
have been determined by voting.
But a vast majority of
other decisions have not.
And so now with the ability
to capture information
from people who have an
interest either because they
have participated
in some process,
they have been customers of a
particular business, the costs
of collecting that information
have dropped dramatically
to the point where it is now
cost-feasible to have detailed,
granular feedback about every
restaurant, about every hotel,
about every nail salon,
about every small business.
And so given that we have
that kind of information,
the way in which we
collect this feedback
is naturally aligned
with interested parties
contributing information.
And so I think part of
the reason why there's
a higher level of peer-to-peer
trust in the sharing economy
than from, say,
population-scale voting systems
is that it's more
specific to something
that you are interested in.
And the participation is also
from people whose incentives
are aligned, who actually
are informed about the thing
that they are providing feedback
on rather than randomly being
asked to make a choice of
pretty coarse granularity.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ARUN SUNDARARAJAN: All right.
So the question was you focused
on the successes, what have
we learned from the failures?
I'll answer that in two ways.
First is to say that there are
certain industries that I don't
think will make the transition
to crowd-based capitalism
any time soon, like
high-end health care,
meaning complex, health
care-- open heart surgery,
unlikely to be a crowd-based
platform for that.
I wouldn't use it if
there was one, for sure.
On the other hand, I
cut my finger cooking.
And I need someone
to stitch it up.
I can certainly see a
crowd-based platform
where registered nurses who
live in the neighborhood
come and provide that for
a couple hundred dollars,
once the trust gets
to the level where
we can delegate health
care responsibility
to a registered provider.
So there are certain
industry segments,
like heavy manufacturing,
those things
are likely to maintain
their industrial capitalism
structure.
There've also been a
number of platforms
in the sharing economy that
have started and then shut down.
Some of them are just
because of VC enthusiasm.
There's a lot of
money sloshing in.
Bad ideas will get funded.
It's the part of the process
of creative destruction.
I think some of
the platforms, you
have to get to-- there's a
distinction, for example,
between offering
something on demand,
instantly-- you place
the order and it
comes to you-- versus
offering something
as a scheduled service.
I think we're
starting to realize
that some services-- on-demand
laundry, for example-- lend
themselves better to
the scheduled approach
rather than I ask
you to pick it up.
And you come and pick
it up in an hour,
where the logistics start
to become more complicated.
I think one of the things
we've learned from some
of the failures is that you
need a certain immense-- just
because Uber and Lyft are
successful with the on-demand,
instantaneous model doesn't mean
that every other industry needs
that.
If I want a ride, I
want it right now.
And I want it in three minutes.
But if I want my laundry done,
or I want dinner this evening,
it's quite feasible that
the successful model
is going to be one where instead
of saying I want it now, bring
it to me, you might
say in the morning,
well, this is what I want,
and I want it at 7:00 o'clock,
or come and pick it up
at 3:00 in the afternoon.
And those models may
end up dominating.
I guess what else
have we learned
from some of the failures?
Well, there've been
a number of attempts
to create peer-to-peer
rental markets for assets
other than cars and
space in your home.
If you think about it, space
in your home and your car
are the two typically
most valuable
assets an individual has.
The home is utilized
at a high level,
but it's so valuable relative
to a person's typical income
that even a small
amount of slack
can overcome the
transaction costs,
and you've got a
market like Airbnb.
A car is underutilized
vastly, and so
peer-to-peer rental
markets work.
But they haven't worked for
things like vacuum cleaners
and power drills and all of
these celebrated 2012 sharing
economy examples.
I think what's happening
there is that the transaction
costs are still too high.
The value that is created
from lending clothing--
every city I've gone to has a
peer-to-peer clothing rental
market that is struggling
with logistics.
So I think once we
get to the point
where the objects
that we're sharing
are self-aware-- the
digitization of the physical--
an object knows where it is.
It knows how much
it's being used.
And it can call on
transport, if needed.
And so if there's a drone
delivery network that
can pick it up and
take it, then you're
going to lower the
transaction costs to the point
where a lot more peer-to-peer
rental markets will
become feasible for
lower value assets.
I think about this, and I
think about the only thing more
frightening than a network
of drones flying above me
is if they're carrying
power drills as well.
So it may not be the power
drills that start it,
maybe the $500 dress that you
want to rent from someone.
I think those are
some of the things
that we've learned from
some of the failures,
that the transaction
costs are too
high for certain peer-to-peer,
and that on-demand may not
be instantaneous.
On-demand may not be-- unit
economics may not work out,
but a scheduled
model may work well.
Well, I don't have
a good answer.
So the question was, we
had a high level of trust
in the 1950s.
In the United States,
people would hitchhike.
That trust level
seems to have dropped.
What happened?
And will we see a
similar drop-off
in trust in the sharing economy
as it gets more commonplace?
So I don't know why
trust has dropped off
so much in especially the US
economy over the last 40 years.
I've been tracking these numbers
from the General Social Survey.
They ask people as part
of that [INAUDIBLE].
Every year or two years,
they have the giant survey
about everything from like
gun control to choice.
And one of the
questions they ask
is, in general, you feel
people can be trusted
or you can't be too careful.
And the response is
a reliable metric
that we've got 40 years of
data about the level of trust
in society.
So I've seen that number fall
from about 50% in the mid '70s
to about 30% today.
So our level of trust in
other people, in general,
has gone down.
The fall has been steepest
among people under the age of 35
where less than one in five
people under the age of 35
today believe that other
people are trustworthy.
The thing is that in parallel
with this fall in general trust
has been an increase in
digitally mediated trust.
We're getting more accustomed
to reading digital cues
because we're growing
up reading Yelp reviews,
reading Amazon reviews,
understanding what's real
and what's fake about a
Facebook or LinkedIn network.
And so our ability
to make assessments
about someone else based on
digital information about them
is getting more sophisticated.
And that's part
of the reason why
when although the average
person will definitely not
hitchhike in the United
States, it's likely
that as city to city
car-sharing comes along,
people will participate in it.
Or the average
person wouldn't stand
on the side of the road in
France and hitch a ride,
but they would trust the
person on BlaBlaCar enough.
Will this trust
dissolve over time?
I hope not.
I think that an alternative
path that it could take
is that it could raise
the general level of trust
in society because more and
more of our everyday economic
activities are going to be
taking that leap of trust
with someone we don't know.
The vast majority of these
are positive experiences.
And so, as we get accustomed,
as we stop buying from brands
and start to get our rides,
our food, our accommodation
from other people, and
as these end up being
positive experiences,
this may start
to inject a greater
level of general trust
in society because
we'll discover
through our own experience
that most people are,
in general, trustworthy.
And now that we also have
these digital feedback systems,
it raises the bar for
behavior, as well.
Because if you were running a--
if you were, say, selling food
to your community in
the past and someone
had a bad experience, maybe
they'll tell their friends.
But it's not going to permeate
across your entire demand base.
Today if you're selling
food through Josephine
and someone gets food
poisoning, the entire community
is going to know instantly
through your feedback.
And that will shutter
your business.
So it raises the bar
on you to behave,
take actions that
are more trustworthy.
AUDIENCE: So how do you see
the long-term [INAUDIBLE]?
ARUN SUNDARARAJAN: Well,
to the second point,
it seems likely that there
will be some things-- there
are some people who stay in
an Airbnb because they say,
oh, it's cool.
It's different.
It's not what my parents did.
But Airbnb is
becoming, for example,
increasingly the
preferred solution
for more and more people.
It's not quite there yet
for business travelers.
But for people who
are taking a vacation,
it's not so much about it
being cool and fringe anymore.
I mean, they are
the biggest provider
of short-term accommodation
in the world now.
So it's no longer
a fringe activity.
I think that kind of model will
persist because it will just
become normal.
It enters the cultural dialogue.
It becomes the way in which
you find accommodation.
You don't think twice about
staying in a hotel now.
It's just the thing
that you do when
you travel to another city.
And so I don't think the
acceptance or rejection
of Airbnb in a decade is going
to be colored by, is this cool?
Or, is this fringe?
Or, is this not?
It'll just be the way in
which you find accommodation.
To the economic
factors, well, that's
an industry by
industry question.
The unit economics
associated with Airbnb
are fundamentally superior to
those of the hotel industry
because you are tapping
into excess capacity.
And so the unit economics
of peer-to-peer car rental
are fundamentally
superior to that of Hertz
because Getaround now has more
members in the San Francisco
Bay area than Zipcar.
They've done it in an
extremely short period of time.
And this is not
Uber-level funding.
They're a modest-sized company,
but they're already that big.
How are they able
to scale so rapidly?
Well, because scaling
there involves
tapping into existing cars,
not leasing a fleet of cars
yourself.
So I'm optimistic
about many slices
of crowd-based capitalism
here because the underlying
economics are just
fundamentally superior.
I think most of the
subsidies that we've
seen from venture
money have been
in the point-to-point
transportation
space, the ride-sharing space.
Over there, we've got
another transition
that's coming that
all of you are
familiar with, the autonomous
vehicle transition.
And that will take
longer than, I think,
Uber and Lyft
think it will take.
I don't expect that we will
have autonomous vehicles that
are mass market and
widespread in five years.
I'm sure the
technology is ready,
but there's a
cultural acceptance.
There's a regulatory acceptance.
There's an interaction
between the autonomous
and the non-autonomous.
All of these need
to be ironed out.
And it's mostly the
acceptance factor.
But those start to come in.
And so as these
subsidies start to phase,
the cost structure will
start to improve to the point
where, for an increasing
fraction of the population,
on-demand transportation
will be as economical or more
economical than buying a car.
I mean, right now
it's the case for me.
I live in Manhattan.
75% of us don't own cars
anyway because owning
a car is just useless.
You can't find parking.
It's really expensive.
And so you use subway.
You use taxi.
You use on-demand
transportation.
And you have similar, like San
Francisco, LA, the big cities.
But at least half the
population of the US
lives in a densely
enough populated area
where if the costs fall enough,
the on-demand alternative
will be cost comparable
to owning your own car.
And so if you think about
that, you think about the fact
that Americans spend
over a trillion dollars
every year buying new and
used cars-- just buying,
forget about maintenance
and all of that.
So what the investors
in Lyft and Uber
and there are for
others-- Go-Jek
in Indonesia, Grab in
Singapore, Didi Chuxing
in China, Ola in India--
all of them are unicorns.
But what the VCs are betting
on isn't that these guys
will be the new taxi.
What they're betting
on is that they
will capture a slice of
the trillions of dollars
that people spend
buying cars every year.
So if you capture
5% of that trillion,
you've justified
your valuations.
So over there, I think
the model will work,
but it'll expand dramatically
as the unit economics improve
because of automation.
Well, there's one
more point, as well.
Because of automation, but
before that, because also that
you have gotten
enough of a density
where genuine carpooling
through a market
starts to become possible.
And so you've got people driving
from San Francisco to Mountain
View and then driving back from
Mountain View to San Francisco.
Even today, you
look at the highway.
Most people have one car.
Most cars have one person.
If you get enough of a density
in a market where you can start
to get people to
share that space,
then that model starts
to become viable.
And so that's another thing that
will drive down unit economics.
But I'm not making a
living driving the car.
I happen to be driving it from
one place to another anyway.
And I'm just making
some extra money
by having someone else
subsidizing my costs.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ARUN SUNDARARAJAN: Well, I can't
quantify how much of a reason--
so the question was,
I argued that part
of the reason why someone would
become a driver on BlaBlaCar
is social reasons.
To what extent is this
a convincing reason
and how much is a similar reason
present in other industries
in the sharing economy?
My conversations
with BlaBlaCar have
suggested that this
is a big part of why
people supply on BlaBlaCar.
You get lonely traveling a
long distance by yourself.
It's nice to have other
people in the car.
It seems that, on average,
we live in a society
where people have insufficient
connection with other people.
There's a lot of
research that has
suggested that, physiologically,
we need social connection.
There's something
analogous to physical pain
that lights up in
your neural network
when you don't have
enough social connection.
Neurologists call
it social pain.
So that's certainly
part of it that
would cause you to make
a decision that just
purely on the economic
aspects isn't something
that you'd be drawn to.
So it's a combination
of reasons.
I think a lot of
recent Airbnb hosts--
the fastest rate of
growth in Airbnb hosting
tends to be in not the
millennial demographic,
but in the over 50 demographic.
And I think over there, empty
nests, and I have spare space,
and it'll be nice to have
people staying in my home also
plays a role that is
operating in conjunction with,
OK, I can trust
this person enough
and I make some money as well.
So I don't think that
it's the only reason.
Well, the one place where
it's the only reason
is with couch surfing.
Couch surfing is a
platform that allows
you to sleep on someone's
couch in exchange
for letting them sleep on your--
or people sleep on your couch.
But there's no money there
because couch surfing is not
really a marketplace.
It's a social network.
The typical couch-surfing person
goes to a new city and says,
where's the party?
It's not like, I
need a place to stay.
It's a pure gift economy in that
the exchange of accommodation
is purely incidental,
and the real objective
is to build the connection.
So over there, the social
reason is dominant.
But in other situations, it's
a combination of factors.
Well, I mean, you
certainly have a point
with-- so the
question was, there
are a couple of conjectures
that are given about why there's
been a drop in societal
trust over the last 50 years.
One is the sensationalization
by the media of negative events
with increasing intensity.
And the other is, I guess,
flawed regulatory intervention
and reaction to bad
events that have
suppressed certain things that
would have otherwise proceeded
well.
I mean, both are possibilities.
I certainly think that if you
look at the level of trust
or the level of activity
and, as a consequence,
the implied level of trust that
BlaBlaCar users in the United
Kingdom have, it's a little
different from the rest
of Europe.
And that could be attributable,
in part, to the fact
that you don't have the
sensationalized "hitchhiking is
dangerous" kinds of stories
in France and Germany
as much as you do in
the United Kingdom.
And so that's certainly
a possibility,
that certain activities have
been labeled as negative
because of a relatively small
number of extremely bad things
that have happened.
But I think that there is
something more basic that
has happened when it
comes to explaining
that drop of trust--
I mean, I don't
know exactly what it is--
because the drop in the level
of trust in society
hasn't just been
on specific kinds of activities.
It's been fairly
broad-based, which
is why I think the sharing
economy holds so much promise
of re-injecting this trust.
To your second point about is it
flawed regulatory intervention?
If that is the reason,
then the sharing economy
is probably in better shape
because a lot of people
think of these
platforms that we've
talked about as somehow
making an attempt
to reduce regulation.
But that's actually
not the case.
The changes that they're
trying to induce,
or the changes that they
will induce, are different.
They are a change in certain
government regulations
that don't fit anymore
and actually an increase
in total regulation, except
that the regulation is
done by someone other
than the government.
And so if you think about
the amount of regulation that
will be done in a crowd-based
capitalism economy,
it will actually be more.
It just won't all come
from the government.
And where I'm getting to is
that because in some ways
the equivalent to
government regulation that
emerges from a
platform is targeted
at solving a real problem and
is created by a crowd of people.
The chances that
it will be flawed
regulation that might suppress
the activity are a lot lower.
I mean, it's naturally aligned
with encouraging the activity
rather than discouraging it.
So if your conjecture about
regulatory intervention leading
to lower trust is correct,
then the sharing economy
is a solution.
The regulatory systems
of the sharing economy,
they're more participatory.
They're more ethical
in some ways.
They're more targeted at
solving actual market failures.
There's some promise there.
All right.
Thank you very much enjoy.
I enjoyed the discussion.
[APPLAUSE]